hé regarde Morty je suis une jambe par jambe
Morty tout progrès j'ai trouvé la version
de moi qui a tué ma femme tu viens de
manquer
[Musique]
je peux te demander si tu es actuellement un
hologramme ouais ouais attends une
[Musique]
sec fais  nous savons que quelqu'un est sobre, as-tu
bu un jeudi si tu aimes
avoir je toi toi
alors à moi combien de temps faut-il à une société pour
s'effondrer
découvrons que je te le dis mec tu fais une
grosse erreur ici qui est prêt pour  Le
célèbre
spaghetti supp de Rick
perd les imbéciles mais c'est comme ça que je l'aime bébé
je sais que je veux vivre éternellement J'ai dit que j'étais
désolé non tu ne l'as pas dit tranquillement tais-toi
Papa tu as eu un entretien d'embauche n'est-ce pas
Bond à qui est cette voiture dont le pare-soleil
est  c'est quoi un soleil, je me demandais si
vous pouviez m'aider avec une
situation un peu rake, une situation rake
[Applaudissements] et
bien, la dernière était juste
pour choquer, la seule chose que vous voyez sait
[Musique]
c'est
ce que tu dis Rick  voler à travers
l'espace trouver quelque chose peut-être que j'ai une
objection morale Rick et Morty nous sommes
de retour
[Musique]
bébé